Speaker 1: I'm going to play for you today
one of the most outrageous and dangerous comments
I've ever heard from any elected official
ever, and certainly that I have covered on
this program.
Radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor GREENE said that if she had organized
the Insurrection coup Trump riots on January
six, 2021, she would have been armed and they
would have won.
Now, what on earth does it mean that they
would have won?
Well, I think we have some pretty good ideas
of exactly what they mean.
We're going to get to that.
Newsweek reporting Marjorie Taylor GREENE
says MAGA would have won on January six if
she organized it.
What the hell is she talking about?
GREENE was among the high profile guests to
attend and speak at an event hosted by the
New York Young Republican Club.
That's a group that's got upper management
written all over it, huh?
That was in New York City on Sunday evening.
Don Jr was there, Rudy Giuliani was there,
conspiracy theorist Jack Posobiec was there.
And the topic of the Capitol riot came up.
And here is Marjorie Taylor GREENE with again.
Let's see if we can understand exactly what
she means, saying if she had run the riots,
they would have won the riots.
Interesting.
Winning and losing as the framing.
I come to.
Speaker 2: Washington, I swear it.
On January 3rd, I get accused of giving Insurrection
Tours, which I thought was hilarious, but
I couldn't even find the bathroom in the Capitol.
True story.
Then January six happens.
And next thing you know, I organized the whole
thing along with Steve Martin here.
And I want to tell you something.
I've been in and I had organized that we would
have one.
Unidentified: Wow.
Not to mention an arm.
Yeah.
Oh.
Speaker 1: So it would have been a successful,
more heavily armed insurrection if Marge had
been running the thing.
Hmm.
Speaker 2: See, that's the whole joke, isn't
it?
They say that whole thing was planned and
I'm like, Are you kidding me?
A bunch of conservatives, Second Amendment
supporters.
Unidentified: Went in the Capitol without
guns and they say, you know, we organized
that.
I don't think so.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, remember, many of them flew to D.C.,
so how exactly are they going to bring their
guns?
Oh, well, you know, you could check it.
Or it's the fact that there weren't more guns
because remember, there were guns doesn't
really tell us anything about it at all.
And there's no both sides to it.
I mean, this this is this is fascism wannabe.
Important to mention, we have to stop treating
the Republican Party like it's a normal political
party.
I'm not going to do the retro retrospective
rehabilitation of the Republican Party.
I'm not going to do that.
But I will recognize that there was a time
when the disagreements and the differences
with the Republican Party.
We're more sane in nature, I guess, is what
I would say when it was really about how involved
should government be in helping people?
To what degree should the rich be taxed?
What should the top tax rates be?
There was a time where that was most of it.
There was still the crazy stuff.
There was.
I'm not going to pretend that there was there
was there was some of the crazy stuff.
It's all crazy stuff now.
It's all wannabe authoritarian, fascist dictatorships
at this point in time.
Do whatever we need to do.
Suppress speech, control the media, use use
prison or the threat of prison to try to achieve
political is it's there's no both sides at
this point in time Democrats are trying to
figure out how can we get everybody health
care.
Republicans are trying to figure out how can
we use guns to get into office after losing
an election.
Think about that contrast.
Now, I wish you would elaborate on what winning
meant, she says.
We would have won the insurrection if I had
been in charge.
Is she saying we would have successfully overthrown
the government?
Ending democracy as we know it in the country
by installing a dictatorial leader who lost
his election?
Is that the win that she's talking about?
I think it has to be.
I don't know what else it could be.
We have to deal with this political party
not as a normal political party, but rather
as a group of people who want to destroy the
American system of government who don't care
about the Constitution.
Trump just said last week, You can terminate
the parts of the Constitution that you want
when you believe you have been wronged, as
he believes he was wronged in 2020.
We have to treat them for what they are.
Now, there's one other, I guess, alternative
for what it would mean to have one, which
is maybe they would have gotten a few senators
and members of the House killed.
Right.
It wouldn't have just been a demand to hang
Pence.
Maybe they would have done it.
And then he could have declared martial law
and then he could have suspended the election
process and somehow convince people he should
be president for an additional four years.
I don't know, maybe maybe that's what a win
would have looked like.
But that's Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
She should obviously not be a member of the
House.
Lauren Boebert won, but barely.
Madison Cawthorn lost in her very red district.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE easily won.
The real test now is going to be what happens
to these magazines
in 2024?
We'll be following it